good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Friday
why don't you give us a Luke Combs
version of Friday since we all know the
Twitter headed this weekend and we can
just rip the Band-Aid off
okay
um
sorry honestly that's like hard
yeah it's Friday oh yeah drink a beer
and getting my truck
okay Luke Combs would never call a woman
a like you know a respectful King
yet he would never
um but it's Luke Combs weekend for you
I'm excited for you living vicariously
through you jealous of you feeling all
the feelings for you I'm so sorry that
you are not able to join us
um I'm very excited I don't want to like
you know I feel like on a Friday's
episodes a lot of the times I'm like
headed somewhere whether it's like a
weekend away and most of the time like
you like couldn't care less you couldn't
pay me to go right right but this is
definitely a tough pill for you to
swallow and I'm really sorry yeah well I
just hope that Luke gets laryngitis
[Applause]
both shows when you're already at the
hotel
Jackie is wishing negative energy
towards me I reject I reject your energy
I hope that your ball gets hit into the
lake
my ball wow I'm quoting you and you
don't even realize
oh oh yeah your golf video
yeah yeah yeah
um I'm excited you know let's not dwell
on it too much how about that like I'm
just going away for the weekend I'll see
you on Monday
be well maybe you won't
where are you gonna go this could be the
thing that breaks me
um
oh she's she'll be broken yeah
now it's gonna be hard but I keep
waiting I keep waiting for you like no
I'm kidding I hope you have an amazing
time no no no no like honestly I don't
feel that way
you don't wish I have an amazing time
honestly no
no I by the way I'm an extremely like
vindictive jealous person like I
understand where you're coming from I
can't even be mad no and like I never
said that before like when you went to
when you guys were going to eras and I
couldn't go like of course I want to
stay I hope you had an amazing time like
it's okay but like this is just a hair
too far it's hitting different yeah
okay well my offer still stands to take
you next weekend in Philly
thank you for the offer
just think about it okay I'll think
about it
just actually I don't think I'm gonna
drive with you for a while
okay well speaking of
Jackie and I yesterday as promised
filmed our kind of a critically
acclaimed long-awaited second mukbang
video ever
um it was uploaded to patreon this
morning so it is an hour-long mukbang
and that's because it was not what we
expected like it kind of turned into
this absolutely miserable Journey
um we routed poorly we planned poorly
um we all we like had High Hopes in the
beginning and then like the second thing
started to go wrong Jackie and I were
both just in like fouls no but like
everything was going wrong yeah starting
with the outer rail like the GPS just
took us the worst way every single time
the we did plan a nice route but
apparently when you search like drive
through fast food on Google and they
give you a place like it's not actually
a drive-through so that's yes someone's
fault we drove like so far for nothing
and you know but we did get food we
mukbanged but not in the way that we
were hoping to no and we tried to really
like find the positives in in the
journey and the pause was there the
positive was Sonic yeah and I don't want
to spoil you know the amazing work that
we did but I highly encourage you to go
over to patreon
um because Sonic is everything and it
was Jackie and I's both first time at
Sonic yeah it was the video is up now
you can watch it now patreon.com toast
it is so long because there was just
like so much Journey
yeah like there's so many unexpected
turns the ratio of like eating
to driving to talking and driving and
singing it's probably like a fifth
100 I was gonna say like 70 30.
70 driving yeah okay so you're saying 30
eating I'm saying 20 okay we're so in
line mathematically let's call it 25.
I hope not sporadically of course let's
call it 25. well I hope everybody enjoys
that a nice you know extra treat on this
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
and get your ass to a Sonic if there's
one near you that's the plural of your
ass to a Sonic maybe when you go on your
road trip this weekend you guys could
stop at times and you could tell Margo
and Emily like you're kind of a
connoisseur on the menu make some
recommendations we actually have routed
our journey to Boston already we will be
stopping at Cheesecake Factory on the
way which I'm happy with mukbang part
three
mukbang part three what are we gonna eat
in the car
you could eat oh does mukbang have to be
in a car
not historically especially where
mukbang originates in Asia it's I think
mostly done at home American mukbang I
don't know what it is about American
culture that we all just like sit in our
car and eat it's fast food but yeah we
mukbang America's version is definitely
giving you know Auto energy what do you
get from Cheesecake Factory
depends on the day depends on like where
I'm at in my health Journey
um if you're if you're splurging I love
the orange chicken okay
I love a grilled chicken sandwich
I love
um
that's pretty much it if you're being
skinny
like grilled chicken rice okay
cool no bread yeah
well I hope you enjoy it
thanks and then I hope you get food
poisoning and then I hope your car
crashes no no no nothing crazy who are
you wearing rollers for
oh I got a blow out this morning just
cause like I don't want to be you know
doing my hair all weekend we're going to
the concert tonight and tomorrow night
and I want my hair just to be like taken
care of for me so I figured while we
were podcasting I let my front pieces
set and wear my rollers that's so nice
you could drive with them too
I was thinking that but they are
annoying me are they yeah the velcro
rollers like are good because you don't
need Clips but they're not like the most
sturdy but you could just put a clip in
it would become sturdy turdy's not
feeling sturdy you could be dirty sturdy
with a I could but then I find when
you put a clip in with your roller like
it leaves a little indentation you know
gotta get the right clip which I
certainly don't have here yeah unlimited
yeah agreed you gotta invest in a clip
so before I head out on my journey which
you know we're hoping here is going to
be terrible
um we've got some business to attend to
we've got fast five stories we've got
you know some dog business oh my God
wait I spoke on a panel last night it
was fabulous
um and then you know before and after
there was like little schmooze with
people who work at the company and of
course you know the toasters found their
way to me and one of the toasters who
was fabulous introduced me to her
co-worker guess what his name was
I don't know guess
Harry
no no no something really toasty
I don't know
come on
I really I can't my brain can't expand
that far
Bryson
Streisand I said Bryson as Bryson of the
Bryson streisands and what did he say
he didn't know what I was talking about
because he was just the co-worker of the
toaster just the co-worker wow nice
fella Bryson is here at my feet catching
up on his Z's because he and I and the
whole family had a horrible night's
sleep thanks to the little angel baby
Harry who woke up at 11 30 and didn't go
back to sleep until 3 30.
little angel baby Harry it was really
brutal like he's wakes up a lot in the
night and he's been falling back asleep
like a little faster because he just
sleeps with us but he was just up like
what do you do when they're just up at
11 30.
did Harry like have some caffeine or
something no that's that's what it was
he was just like ready to play he was
singing like it was we tried everything
and honestly I know it's like torture
but it sounds like heaven no I know for
a while it was but then I was really
starting to fall asleep and like he
really he wasn't yeah and then he kept
me up and then when he finally
eventually falls asleep then you have to
start falling asleep I didn't fall
asleep till like four last night and I
had oh my God before like when he woke
up at 11 30 I was still reading
so well the weekend couldn't be coming
at a better time for you alarm Free
Living I'm so sorry yeah no it it's so
if I'm crabby today just please okay see
that's why I always tell everyone when
I'm on my period because if I'm crabby I
think context is important so thank you
for sharing that and I know you actually
want me to have an amazing time this
weekend it's just the exhaustion getting
to you no that part I meant
I'm kind of living for Krabby Jackie I
know I hate to be her but like and then
and then I hate to be her but she lives
inside me she does and of course when
it's like 3 30 then I'm like so stressed
about you know what time I have to wake
up and then I have to do the toes and
I'm so tired and I'm so angry and it's
just it was stressful
I'm so sorry your crappy energy is 100
earned I will not take it personally and
I'm kind of looking forward to the
crabby energy you're gonna be giving
these really turnt stories oh okay can't
wait to do so also I just wanted to
share something so funny because last
night before I exported the Vlog like we
did something so technologically savvy
Claudia watched the Vlog like we
FaceTime and I shared my screen
and so we watched it together through
screen sharing yeah and I told Zach like
he because he want he was like watching
clips of the Vlog while I was editing it
and I'm like by the way we're about to
watch it so if you want to like sit down
and watch with us and literally halfway
through I was like trying to take
pictures like for three minutes of my
chip which like just being stupid and he
was like are are we being filmed and I
was like what do you mean he's like this
is a live viewing oh my God Jackie okay
he thought that we Jackie we were
recording like that people were watching
us watch the Vlog watch and I'm like
have you been sitting here the whole
time thinking that you're on camera okay
because you know I was really thinking
because I kept looking at you guys while
we were watching I'm like it's literally
so sweet like Zach thinks were so funny
and interesting because like no matter
what whenever I'm showing Ben something
the Vlog is 54 minutes so I'm like okay
after 10 minutes even you know somebody
who loves us dearly is gonna get like
all right can I go home now I was like
Zach is so attentive he is such a doll I
really don't give him enough credit for
being so supportive of our work and and
now I know he just thought he was being
filmed yeah he thought that he was on
camera I'm like you think I would sit
here on camera like this like just
taking pictures of my chip witch I'm
like in dying that's the cutest like
thing ever but I am crushed like I
thought he was really supporting us I
need to try and think eventually he did
like go to the other side of the couch
and like stop watching the Vlog but I
don't know if it was right when he
realized he wasn't being recorded wait
that's truly like the funniest thing
ever it was so funny and I wanted to
tell you but I was on mute because we
were screenshot yeah so oh my God that's
so precious I can't
that's literally the most precious thing
yeah
oh I just thought of today's title
I just feel like I want to say it
because like we always forget okay
sturdy turdy and crabby Jackie something
along those lines just giving like our
energies okay pending nothing better she
hates it sometimes like when we put our
names in the title we can't do it all
that often and we do it
I don't really feel like we do
we don't do it like every day but sound
off in the comments what do you think
about the title sturdy turdy and crabby
Jackie it's just when you think you have
to think about it in the context of the
charts and like what people
listen to Gravity the charts like I
can't keep living for the charts the
charts like really I think it's becoming
like a toxic platform for me I have to
stop living for the charts like I'm
sacrificing my own happiness and
creativity for the charts
I don't think that you are I don't think
that no I believe I truly genuinely
believe that I am I don't think that
anybody could get you to do something
that you didn't want to do the charts
could the charts could but they don't
because they're a reflection of of
Claudia of turdy's will
hurt his will okay that could be a title
a reflection of turdy's will yeah but we
can't have our names in the title I'll
make him exception now I'm crabby Jackie
totally and I'm sorry
the stories we need to round out the
week with these some updates some
updates put a pin in it actually yeah I
feel like three of them are updates yeah
exactly so without further adieu here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know before we round out the week
and the past five stories that you need
to know before we round out the week are
brought to you by BarkBox a monthly
themed box of original toys delicious
treats and Unleashed joy for this Choice
brother in your life so I have been
Embark when I knew I was getting a dog
the actual first thing I did was
subscribe to BarkBox because keeping up
with like treats toys they go through
that stuff so fast and having it come
monthly is so helpful and they do it so
cute at BarkBox every box is tailored to
your dog's unique needs and personality
and it's designed to make them happy
BarkBox is made by bark the dog obsessed
company with one goal just to make dogs
as happy as they make us and playtime
isn't just for pups it's also for the
pup parents every BarkBox is designed to
bring dogs and their humans together
opening your monthly BarkBox becomes a
special tradition for the whole family
it's also hard to beat the value and
convenience of Bart box every month
you're getting high quality dog goodies
delivered right to your door and it's
making your dog so happy so yes it's way
more cost efficient to get it all in one
box it's you know you're getting tons of
treats toys and they're always themed
it's so cute like in February they do
like Valentine's Day they have like the
cutest themes and it's so special and
Theo loves it and of course we've got a
great deal for you guys if you have a
dog in your life it's not too late to
sign them up for BarkBox and if you have
you know a puppy coming and you're
trying to prep like what do I do sign up
for BarkBox it'll save you so much time
so sign up now and BarkBox will double
your first box for free so that's twice
the toys treats and chews so to start
spoiling your dog visit barkbox.com
toast that's bark b-a-r-k box.com slash
toast barkbox.com
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is also
brought to you by Dipsy a new sponsor
that I'm very excited about so whether
you're lounging by the pool soaking up
the sun in your own backyard or stuck on
a long commute Dipsy stories is your
passport to a world of sun-kissed
Adventures and Unforgettable Encounters
this summer so Dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women so if you're
an audiobook early if you're a smut
girly this is the app for you so they
bring scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and realistic characters
discover stories about Second Chance
romances adventurous vacation Flings hot
and heavy hookups you know they have a
lot of my favorite tropes friends to
lovers they're super inclusive they have
stories for straight and queer listeners
and 56 of stories are voice acted by
people of color you can now listen to
spicy audios by your favorite Tick Tock
creators they're attentive to your every
need they prioritize your pleasure and
have voices that will make you melt new
content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore they also
have soothing sleep stories they have
Wellness sessions and sexy written
stories to read
so let Tipsy be your go-to place to
spice up your me time explore your
fantasies relax and unwind or even heat
things up with a partner for listeners
of this show Tipsy is offering an
extended 30-day free trial when you go
to dipsystories.com toast that's 30 days
off of full access for free when you go
to
dipsystories.com toast Dipsy is spelled
d-i-f- excuse me
d-i-p-s-e-a-dipsystories.com toast
d-i-p-s-e-a stories.com toast you need
to be the face of Dipsy story stories I
need to be the voice
totally it's audio smut yeah it's
literally everything
our first story Ariana Grande is dating
her Wicked co-star Ethan Slater after
Dalton Gomez split
so apparently Ari's dating Broadway Alum
Ethan Slater who is her co-star in the
upcoming film adaptation of wicked
sources confirmed to people uh One
Source says Ariana and Dalton separated
in January she and Ethan recently began
dating and he is separated from his wife
Reps for both stars have not returned
multiple requests for comment she said
to play Glinda in Wicked uh the movie
and he's playing Bach the love interest
of alphaba's sister Nessa
so I think everyone went on a collective
Journey when they heard this like oh my
God Ari has a new man it's Ethan Slater
who and then going to look him up and
being like Oh and then doing further
research and finding out this man is in
fact married so so then everybody went
on like Instagram stock Rampage trying
to figure out you know the last time he
posted a photo the last time he posted a
photo was I believe Mother's Day which
you know you can post for the mother of
your child without being you know that's
the sign of a good parent you know I'm
Excuse me a good co-parent is that like
you can wish you know the father or
mother of your child a happy mother or
Father's Day so it doesn't it's not
necessarily incriminating then you know
Dumont came out and was like no they're
fully married Ariana's hung out with
them a bunch of times and you know the
wife was completely blindsided by this
affair and then you know everybody then
again did some research and Ari kind of
has like a track record of being like a
feeling you know man Unfaithful Queen
you know there was Big Sean who you know
Naya Rivera there was some overlap there
was of course Pete Davidson who I
believe broke up with uh Cassie David
like four minutes before he went on a
date with Ariana Grande like she kind of
you know and you know I do not in any
way approve of you know stealing other
people's men but having said that you
know what we said earlier this week
Ari's just kind of this like you know
the seven husbands of Ariana Grande Vibe
like I'm also here for her like kind of
just like not giving a she's just
she's the usurper
yeah literally and like if she leans
into it like whatever you know just just
keep your man away from Ari yeah I think
this time is the most messed up just
because he's married and they have a kid
um but people are responsible for their
own actions and if this man's gonna step
out on his wife
Ferrari then like he needs to be held
accountable for that a hundred percent
and like you really can't I
what's that I think it's from I forget
what it's from you can't lose something
you never had like this man
was gonna leave or he was gonna cheat
like he was so easily persuaded you know
yeah I'm not sure that directly applies
here it doesn't it doesn't but it's a
good quote
a beautiful quote what movie is that
from because you can't lose something
you never had she says it keeps like
breaking up but they like weren't in
a good relationship
I'm finding it something you never had
maybe I think his name was like Chad or
something
oh yeah of course I'm sorry How to Lose
a Guy in 10 Days when they're like
fighting outside in the yellow dress
well you can't lose something you never
had then because they never were in a
real relationship right this is kind of
giving that sort of vibe
I feel like I've been saying not just in
today's episode but today's episode
especially but like all week like saying
Vibe and energy so much and I absolutely
have to stop like those are not real
words they have no real meaning they
have they have no substance and I just
keep saying like that's the kind of
energy we're giving I found I sound like
such a stereotypical I need to
stop saying it I 100 agree I feel that
way about myself all the time and the
question I always ask is like what word
did we use before Vibe or energy we're
introduced into the vernacular like five
years ago like when maybe we didn't
maybe we were just speaking differently
maybe we were saying different things
maybe we were saying something but like
I don't know how I went to a party and I
didn't like the vibe was off like how
what would I have said okay how was
let's okay ask me how the party was how
was the party
not so great why
I don't know I just didn't feel like the
um it's impossible the Ambiance was
really My Vibe right no it's
so
I always think about that especially as
it pertains to the word Vibe because
sometimes it's the only word for the job
but it was only really introduced yeah
like colloquially a few years ago so
what the did we say before
I'm not entirely sure also I feel like
on this podcast we are always trying to
update our vernacular and like our
vocabulary we're always learning new
words acrimonious so you know at least
we're doing both while we're also you
know being dumb and saying bye by every
other word we're also learning new words
what's the word of the day let's let's
go to Miriam Webster I got it okay also
in the meantime maybe we could find a
synonym for vibe that we could introduce
I just want to start like that oh my god
you're kidding me oh my God I'm by the
way we're living in a simulation we're
living in a simulation what's the word
of the day acrimonious sir Bryson no
okay tell me if you know why we're
living in this emulation okay the word
of the day is ameliorate
we love the word ameliorate I'm always
talking about how the only sat word that
ever really penetrated my vocabulary was
ameliorate and that was because I had
this app that gave you Clues and
ameliorate was about this girl Amelia
who was I think like you know really
unhappy in her life and she needed to
ameliorate that and make it better
ameliorate means to make something such
as a problem better or more tolerable so
it sounds like you don't need the word
of the day you're kind of like already
on top of it no this is like the most
fruitless Endeavor I've came to the word
of the day to learn a new word and it
was the only word I actually wanted you
know well then maybe that means you know
every like all the words don't you feel
like that's crazy yeah but that's um
I've told the ameliorate story on the
podcast before I feel I I've heard it
before and I don't think that's
something we would talk about like
offline no we we tuck offline
literally don't talk about the English
language we don't talk about SAT prep
oh my God I'm freaking
um okay what were you talking about
before we got here Ariana Ari so she has
this new man
um and you know what I'm I'm never on
gonna you know defy defy I can't
do defy gravity I'm never gonna justify
or defend I was gonna say defy I was
gonna say defy
defend or Justify and I came out to buy
you know unfaithfulness
now I know there are certain situations
where like people truly can't help
themselves and you know love is you know
blinding I just I saw a picture of this
man and I just feel like she could have
controlled herself
it's not that you know like tantalized I
just feel like it's when you're on a
movie set especially away from home it's
kind of like Camp it's Camp goggles and
this is so hot this is the hottest guy
at camp that summer
I'm sure you know it is a musical
theater production straight men be that
many heterosexual men oh my God I saw
the funniest tweet it was like well good
job guys we made nepo baby such a big
deal we could have had Ben Platt playing
Bach
and he's gay so like this never would
have happened oh is that why he's like I
didn't feel like that was a good tweet
jacket it was like a joke and I
definitely misquoted it but like okay
nobody I love he still could have played
Bach and why don't I remember Bach
I think he's the one who says can I wear
this out to the party tonight no that's
Fiero
Fiero yeah yeah I don't remember a
lot of like the male characters in
Wicked because to me there's only
alphaba and Glinda yeah but she does
have the sister
the wicked one no no alphabet has a
sister Nessa
Elf oh yeah oh wait glinda's sister is
the wicked witch no
uh no
that way glinda's no sorry alphabet is
the wicked yeah yeah this is her origin
story sorry and so her sister is Nessa
and they're just like sissies
oh yeah and her sister like doesn't have
green skin and like that's where Sheila
and she's different yeah
sounds like he's kind of an irrelevant
character I can't believe he even had
any scenes with Glinda
yeah I don't think this is going to be
the one the one by any by any means like
I think when filming wraps this raps
yeah except now filming's not gonna wrap
for a while because of the strike right
right right whereas they were almost
done filming
yeah I read somewhere that they were 10
days away from being done yeah so now
they're probably like holed up together
waiting out the strike
so true the strike is another okay this
is another rom-com coming out of the
strike love affair she was able to ward
off Temptation like the whole time
they're filming the movie and she's like
10 more days like and then and same for
him like he's like I'm not gonna look at
Ari my head's not gonna turn Ferrari I
have 10 more days and then the strike
goes into effect and then they like
maybe maybe for some reason they have to
get to like closer quarters you know
because like budgets are cutting so they
have to like yeah yeah hotels they are
being slashed yeah so they have to like
share a room or like they haven't enjoy
something
okay I just want to say back to like
actual real life I don't think that this
news could have come at a worse time for
Ethan's later because like he can't you
know Escape at work he has to be home
all the time he's not allowed to work
um and his wife just found out about
this affair and like presumably they
were living together you don't think
he's still in London and like I'm sure
she came with him it's a long time and
like they're a family
that's true and they're not like that
famous like when you're such a major
celebrity and like your partner goes
abroad for a few weeks like you're used
to it and you have your own projects but
I feel like she probably came with him I
know it depends maybe she has stuff
going on at home
maybe maybe she can't take off work
Maybe
I don't think I don't think she's there
I don't think Ari would do it under her
nose
oh but Dumas sorry Dumas had said that
she that Ari had spent time with them so
meaning she was there she might have
visited set
Maybe
when she heard about the strike she was
like oh you're in London we get some
time off in London together Wimbledon
right
Wimbledon
hey well we'll keep you posted but
oh he's got a new man
and I feel like you know on the heels of
Jonah Hill and Ariana Grande this is not
a good month for normies
for normies
yeah two failed celebrity Normie
relationships yeah but we also could
cite two failed celebrity celebrity
relationships like our next story but we
know that but we know that you know
I think it's just relationships you know
the statistic 50 of marriages don't work
out so true so 50 of your ships are
gonna sink
so true and that's just a risk you take
when you're a shipbuilder
it's such it's such a kind of um
high-risk job
our next story is a report that
apparently Joe mangionello's intense
desire to have kids led to his divorce
from Sofia Vergara so page six is
reporting that Joe manganello chose to
end his seven-year marriage because they
just disagreed on the topic of children
a source close to Joe tells us that he's
always wanted to be a dad and that those
feelings have only intensified in recent
years he's 46 Sophia's 51. it's unclear
where she stood on the subject when the
two said I do in November 2015 but we're
told she may have been open to it at the
time she already is a mom to her 31 year
old son Manolo who she shares with her
ex-husband Joe Gonzalez and as we know
she was dragged into a lengthy Court
battle over custody of two frozen
embryos from her 2013 IVF treatments
with then fiance Nick Loeb who sought to
bring them to term and though the judge
ultimately ruled in Sophia's favor the
experience might have had an effect on
good news about having kids
I don't know if I like 100 believe this
because I really feel before you enter
into a marriage especially after dating
for a long time you're really on the
same page when it comes to kids and of
course people can change their minds
um I don't know I don't know either this
doesn't seem to make a lot of sense to
me oh I'm sorry also this is gonna sound
mean but I think it's just facts like I
also don't think you can really change
your mind when you've decided to marry
someone who's 51 like biology is real
you know at some point women stop you
know being fertile right well when they
got married I guess she was like 40.
four but which is still like at the very
end of a biological clock it's like if
you do want to have kids when you get
married that's something you should say
because maybe like then you would start
something but to ask be with someone
who's 51 and then be disappointed that
you're not having kids like that just
seems kind of unfair and I agree with
you that I don't necessarily believe
that this is the reason but I mean it's
possible that when they got married he
was like fine not having kids yeah
because he's like you know 46 now too
but maybe one day you wake up and you're
like I want kids of course no and by the
way we'll know if this ends up being
true if Joe manganiello's next
girlfriend's really young
is so important to him he'll date
someone in like late 20s early 30s
because those are your prime years yeah
and if he winds up having a kid oh
excuse me Prime fertility years I'm Not
Who was Don Lemon literally said women
are in their Prime when they're in their
30s sorry that's not what I meant not me
getting canceled because I literally
just said what John Lemon said I meant
child bearing Prime excuse me yeah
yeah
oh my God I'm literally burying myself
change the subject okay our next story a
little update on Graham gate TMZ reports
that Raquel gave up her dog
to a shelter before the jog went to
James so
um James had posted some photos with
graham that we reported yesterday the
dog he once shared with Raquel claiming
he's back with the pup for good
sources with direct knowledge told TMZ
that James found out through a mutual
friend that Raquel was trying to find a
new home for Graham she didn't connect
with him directly then I by the way oh
sorry then it was uh Source said that
Graham was recently dropped off at a
shelter and was having behavioral issues
mostly a biting problem the Vanderpump
dog Foundation got alerted to Graham's
situation and worked out the reunion
with James and his Pooch The Source says
James says the dog in training classes
and they've seemed to work they're told
James is very happy to have Graham back
yeah I heard that like Lisa heard I mean
I read Lisa was really integral in
facilitating the um reunion the reunion
which is great that Vanderpump dogs that
got alerted to it and people are really
mad at Raquel for just you know it
should be your absolute like last la
like you are dying and there's no like
shelters really supposed to be a last
resort especially for a dog that's like
domesticated that's been in you know in
a family for so long to just be dropped
off at a shelter it's like so scary
people are really mad at Raquel
especially because I am sure if she just
even she didn't have to reach out to
James have somebody reach out to James
and be like I can't do this anymore I'm
sure Raquel's mental health is a huge
factor in this I don't know if I
necessarily believe the biting thing I
think that's just what people say to be
like to take oh I can't have in my house
he's biting
um and there are dogs who bite of course
but I don't feel like that was this sort
of situation
um people are really mad at Raquel
because she could have just had you know
I don't know who's on her side but like
literally anyone just take the dog and
be like James please
I feel like sadness for Raquel and
initially I was like I don't blame her
for not being able to take care of the
dog she probably can't even take care of
herself
um so I don't want to like judge her so
too harshly because I feel like what
she's going through is unimaginable
especially given the fact that she's had
you know weeks of treatment
I just really like you know I'm glad
James got the dog but damn I'm glad
James got the dog I don't know that this
is the whole story it's not making sense
to me and I want to remember judgment
until I don't know if we'll regret the
whole story I think she would have to
like be on the show you know no one on
the Vanderpump Camp is gonna like take
the time to vouch to share you know what
really happened but it's like reminding
me obviously of Lucy Lucy apple juice
where it's like you first heard like
dorit's dog wound up at a shelter and
you're like oh my God but then when you
hear what actually happened how she like
re-homed it to a person and everything
that she could because she couldn't keep
the dog in her home with her kids in the
biting well that's the other thing to
read had kids so I think people were a
little bit you know less quick to judge
because when you we do have a dog who
bites it's more of a big deal when you
have tiny kids running around who can't
you know critically think and defend
them right but you don't know that like
Raquel didn't give Graham to her sister
who has kids like I just feel like
there's more to this story Fair it
doesn't make sense
it just doesn't make enough sense to me
I feel like there's pieces missing so I
am not going to judge based on just this
that is completely fair and you know
what probably a good point and it's not
fair it's not fair to be like I'm gonna
believe this story and I actually don't
believe the biting part
I'm not so true you know got me being
selective right right so I I'm gonna
wait and see but I don't know when like
does she even have you go on Instagram
anymore like where she ever will share
her truths
if she gets on the show I'm sure it'll
be a a spot line yeah I'm sure they'll
talk about it even if she's not on the
show James will you know there's a huge
update on his life and Graham has been
you know my puppy party like Grandma's
been a character on the show so I'm sure
it'll be a storyline whether or not we
got Raquel side remains to be seen yeah
and I just wonder how they knew it was
Graham
yes well chip the chip has like Graham
lettuce I don't know what I don't know
what the chip you know all most dogs who
are like domesticated and live as pets
are chipped I don't know what
information exactly the chip gives
actually yes I do because I filled it
out it gives like contact info owners
yeah it does oh okay cool
well that's great that the Vanderpump
dog Foundation was able to liaise
yes and fine like not a single dog in
the West Hollywood area gets re-homed
without Vanderpump dogs being alerted
literally
this is good yeah they're doing good
work over there yeah are you ready for
our next story
is our next story that's brought to you
by better help perhaps yes
yes sometimes in life we're faced with
tough choices and the path forward is
not always clear whether you're dealing
with decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement and trusting yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets I just feel like
we're living in crazy times and there's
never really a bad time to just put
yourself first and start taking care of
yourself and therapy is an amazing way
to do that and better help is an amazing
accessible and affordable way to do that
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's done
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge that's
one of the best things I think about
betterhelp is it's super normal when you
start therapy to not jive with like the
first or the second therapist and it can
be really awkward you know to have to
like cancel and move and find someone
new and it's a lot of work to find
someone new better help makes it so easy
it's all done entirely online so when
you do find someone that you love you
can connect with them you know video
chat phone call text whatever medium you
feel most comfortable with and you can
really you know be your most vulnerable
and honest self so let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-petterhelp.com toast if you've
been looking for a sign to start you
know putting yourself first and taking
care of your mental health this might be
it go to betterhelp.com toast today to
get 10 off your first month
today's episode is also brought to you
by the farmer's dog whether you have a
puppy that's a few weeks old or a senior
dog who's seen multiple decades any dog
person like us who knows that the most
valuable thing in the world is spending
time with your pet and the farmer's dog
can help keep them healthy which can
give you more quality time with them the
farmer's dog makes and delivers fresh
healthy dog food it's recommended by
vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from human grade ingredients
in safe clean kitchens it's truly the
best option for your dog at all stages
of life because it's not kibble it's not
canned you know goo it's real food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are extremely processed they can use
much lower lower quality ingredients
than they claim to and they are
difficult to portion accurately the
farmer's dog isn't just higher quality
food they also send food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs it makes it
easy to maintain your dog's ideal weight
which is one of the biggest indicators
of a full healthy life for a dog so when
you sign up for a farmer's dog they'll
ask you a ton of questions about your
dog because you know even Theo and Bruce
they're so similar but they really
require different things when it comes
to diet and so it's really tailored and
super personal a fresh diet has all
sorts of benefits like when Theo
switched his coat seems so much
healthier and shinier his breath oh my
God the breath was like really killing
me
um and they even have easier digestion
and smaller better poops a healthy diet
isn't just important for humans so if
you're
dog is young or old it's always the
right time to begin investing in their
health it can help them keep stay
healthy happy and full years longer so
get 50 off your first box when you go to
the farmersdog.com toast that's 50 five
zero percent off your first box when you
go to the farmersdog.com toast thank you
Claudia
and Bruce are just like us like so
similar uh so different to the untrained
eye like the same person but once you
get to know them they're so different
yeah so personal that and also we were
saying the other day that you are
actually really similar to Bruno in
personality wise and I am very similar
to Theo yes kind of wise
um you know more soft-spoken like
doesn't say everything but when he
speaks it's real nuggets and what Bruno
and I we just say whatever we think
every now and then we're right about
something but mostly it's just a bunch
of crap just a bunch of barking
no and like that Bruno needs to be the
center of attention like he yes what was
that what's that like song or movie or
maybe it's just like a myth where like
that person who doesn't get enough
attention like will die for you cried
wolf no person who doesn't get enough
attention will die
I have literally no idea maybe it's like
an SNL skit that's what it sounds like
no it sounds like um
you know like a myth like a a folklore
Urban legendary Legend yeah are you sure
it's at the boy you cried wolf
um no no oh my God I have no idea this
is um this is not a good Google search
I'm gonna get away oh no literally the
government monitoring you yeah
um so anyway that's just some fun facts
about us which I think makes sense like
that's why you're always with like your
canine man I'm always with canine you
Trail
are you ready for our next story you
could say that me and Bruno have the
same energy and you and Theo have the
same vibe
and that all together we have a great
ambiance
you could and that we're constantly
ameliorating
ameliorating bad vibes yep
ameliorate bad vibes make them good make
them good
our next story is some sad news Tony
Bennett has died at the age of 96 in his
hometown of New York the legendary pop
Jazz and big band vocalist has died
after a seven year battle with
Alzheimer's he was 96. his publicist
confirmed his death revealing that he
passed away in his hometown of New York
His official cause of death has not been
announced yet
I don't think you need an official cause
of death when somebody's 96.
um
it's you know this T Alzheimer's is such
a sad thing for your family to to watch
but to have made it to 96 and to have
such an illustrious career and like
honestly like huge peaks in your career
in your 80s is so impressive and while
this is such a sad way for someone to go
out he really leaves behind like such an
amazing career and amazing Legacy so I
think you know
his life is worth celebrating yes
totally he's won 20 Grammys I feel like
recently he's been introduced younger
audiences he like collabed with Lady
Gaga very often
um and he's just a supreme Talent it was
just so crazy you know when he was
with Lady Gaga and everything because
he's from like the Dean Martin era like
real Frank Sinatra and those are people
who feel like so long ago and who
haven't been alive for a while so he
really was this like Bridge of many
generations
yeah he made history as one of the only
artists to chart new albums in the 50s
60s 70s 80s 90s
2000s 2010s and 2020s that's so crazy
that is your kids
um I think so let me look but also I
didn't really realize like how far back
he went I didn't know it was four kids I
didn't know he was 96 either like
he was such a p John like so cute he has
four kids I'm sure you know
it's a very tough time for them but I'm
wishing them well wishing them well
that's so crazy are you ready for our
fifth and final story
yes someone's living turdy's dream who
they just want who they who they just
won one billion dollar Powerball jackpot
in the heart of downtown LA in the
shadow of poverty and despair of skid
row someone has just won a billion
dollars
um yeah I think this is um of course big
news because you know the Powerball
every time it reaches the bills is
always a big deal but for the ticket to
have bought been bought like right on
the edges of skid row is so
what's the word I'm looking for It's
like a
dichotomy dichotomous you love dichotomy
I do love dichotomy but it's such a
Stark
dark and really highlights the poverty
issue in this country yeah has the
person come forward to claim the ticket
I don't I don't believe yet and I want
to say something because I am happy of
course if it can't be me and let it be
someone you know who deserves it but um
I'm happy that you know this particular
Community is where the the Powerball
ticket was purchased but don't you feel
like it's always in California yeah I do
feel that way and is that because
California is technically the biggest
state population wise I believe it is
yeah like so their odds are higher but
still it is it does beg the question now
maybe California just has like a culture
of people who love lottery tickets you
know by the way California is the
biggest state ranked by population they
have 39 million people as of I believe
2023. Texas is next with 30 million
Florida 22 million New York 19 million
yeah
but still it does feel like it's always
California
it does right and yes population wise it
would make sense for them to be you know
having them like the most Powerball
winners but not every time yeah it's
giving kind of like that Monopoly
documentary should we look into this
what was that called mcmillions that was
a good documentary yeah it was
frustrating
frustrating but good it was really
unbelievable
it was unbelievable and it also felt
like like a victimless crime because
McDonald's was the one who but then
there was a lot of like inter inter
crime between all the different the
actual victims were the people they were
setting up to win
oh yeah they like they literally were
paying money for the rest of their lives
like it yeah put them in debt and not in
the same way that like a lot of lottery
winners go into debt like from what
we're spending but because like you know
the big guys getting tires like no no no
the people who just like chose them to
win they the the corrupt people at
McDonald's were McDonald's third party
agency they said you'll win this money
but you need to pay us every single like
we won our cut
yeah and they and like after everything
there was no money to be given
got it
well I can't wait to hear the story of
the person who won this I hope it wasn't
like you know uh you know a California
businessman just driving through town
you know yeah
I want to know who won it what's also
really funny is recently someone won I
think a billion dollars and he's been
like in the news a lot like we reported
the house that he bought in L.A like you
become like a star yeah he's living the
life yeah he like bought a house like in
a really celebrity like I think about
the house next to the weekend like a
very star-studded neighborhood yeah and
I think if I recall correctly we
commended him for spending his money
exactly how we would spend it yeah he's
been living well I think he told
everyone like don't call me don't text
me I don't know you guys anymore right
if you're from my former life we don't
see each other I won't be picking up the
phone
hilarious he needs a reality show I'm
sure he's you know producing his own
yeah
so I don't believe they have to release
the identity of the person who wins I
think more often than not people want to
because with that kind of attention
comes you know Fame and opportunity and
interviews and that's exciting for
someone
um it's entirely possible we won't find
out who this is but I would love to hear
their story yeah me too
and I'm happy for them I really am
I'm also happy for the IRS who just made
400 million dollars
more now
I think I read on Twitter today it was
like 450. oh cool spend it wisely yeah
don't spend it all in one place
well those are the fast five stories and
I feel so you need to know them before
you embark on your fabulous weekend
other people and for Claudia before you
embark on what I hope to be an extremely
treacherous and enjoyable weekend
I'll do my absolute best to have the
absolute worst time just for you I can't
like should I watch your guys's stories
honestly no like maybe you should you
want me to block you no that hurts more
because now it's like oh you're mad at
me
okay you want to block me no I have I
can exercise my free wish restraint and
yes I'm a very restraint you person I'm
just I need to decide what's going to be
like best for my mental health maybe
watching a Luke Combs concert like by
Carrie sand and scrim is going to be
good for me
so I am going to two shows and I feel
like one of them I'm gonna post so
everyone can see like what's going on in
the other I'm just gonna truly enjoy I
feel like that's such a luxury to be
able to go to two I feel like that
actually hurts more if you're like not
posting oh because she's having too much
fun she's not even posting it's so true
yeah actually I'll post a lot so you
think I'm having a bad time yeah because
I could be she's not even present
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I'll be so not present
you have to laugh or you'll cry I know
I'm not really a fomo person but this is
this is tough but you know what I'll
look at the bright side I don't have to
make the road trip
I don't have to drive with you oh and
Ben can't come
so like I'm driving I hate driving long
distances like it's my least favorite
thing but you're gonna split it with
Emily yeah no I think it'll be like 70
30 with me and Emily yeah
fun times
okay well if you want to see how Claudia
drives and check out her new car and
watch this stuff our faces this
episode's over but you can ever head
over to patreon.com the toast for our
mooc bong Vlog we are trying three fast
food restaurants that we had never been
to before
for the most part and sharing our
thoughts and the journey you also get
like a really nice view of New York
Queens like the bridge it's there's a
lot to see so head on over to Feast for
the senses and we will see you on Monday
A Feast for the senses have a great
weekend love ya bye